bonsoir le 78 lactu sur TVfil 78
l'essentiel de l'information locale
nouvelle édition en direct si vous nous
rejoignez à 18h voici les titres de ce
mardi 28 janvier la finale régionale du
championnat de France de dessert vient
de se tenir à Paris parmi les meilleurs
professionnels et débutants une
ivelinoise Caroline fruchot nous verrons
ses chances d'accéder à l'ultime épreuve
nationale qui se déroulera à Nice en
mars enve c'est l'union d'une entreprise
pas comme les autres ici l'accès à
l'emploi et le maître mot c'est à
trrappe chaque salarié signe un contrat
d'insertion nous ferons le bilan de
cette action avec le directeur de la
structure ouverte il y a un peu plus
d'un an et puis le bassin de latonne au
château de Versailles qui fait po neu un
travail minutieux débuté voici quelques
mois hier c'est le système de
canalisation tricentenaire que l'on a vu
sortir de terre la restauration se fera
sous les yeux du publ tout au long de
l'été on commence avec des images
d'erbus d'irbus groupe à hloncour
anciennement EADS les images qui vont
apparaître dans un instant ce site avec
celui des Mureaux seront durement
touchés par les annonces de suppression
de postes faite hier l'entreprise veut
améliorer sa compétitivité dans la
défense dans l'espace 5800 emplois vont
disparaître en Europe dont 720
uniquement dans les Yvelines un plan de
restructuration qui va s'échelonner
pardon jusqu'en 201 7 aujourd'hui mardi
les syndicats étaient reçus nous
reviendrons sur l'avancée des
discussions dans nos prochaines
éditions le championnat de France de
dessert qui distingue les meilleurs
pâtissiers de France mais attention ici
pas question d'un concours télé pour les
amateurs c'est très sérieux les
candidats se répartissent en deux
catégories les professionnels et puis
les juniors qui sont encore des élèves
dans les établissements hôteliers finale
national au printemps à Nice en
attendant les étapes régionales livrent
leur verdict pour l'île de France
c'était aujourd'hui à Paris claire CAMBI
a suivi les épreuves mais aussi la
préparation de Caroline fruchot
yvelinoise elle prépare un diplôme au
lycée hôtelier à
guillancour en cuisine Caroline fruchot
s'active il est 8h30 elle n'a que 3h
pour réaliser un dessert pour 10
personnes ce mardi ils étaient se
étudiants en paattiti à tenté de se
qualifier pour la finale du championnat
de France du dessert son professeur
attend en retrait il ne souhaite pas la
déconcentrer cela fait maintenant 3 mois
qu'il entraîne Caroline en plus de ses
cours traditionnels c'est très important
donc c'est aussi beaucoup de stress et
voilà on attendant de démarrer une fois
qu'on a démarré je pense que après elle
va se libérer mais voilà enfin je
l'espère Caroline est concentrée sur sa
recette elle a décidé de travailler des
poires et de les décliner de multiples
façons pendant leur préparatif un jury
de travail observe les fait et gestes
des candidats ils jugent leur technicité
leur savoir-faire l'hygiène et attention
il faut que leur réalisation concorde
avec les photos envoyé en AM le jury est
composé de chef pâtissiers réputés la
réussite à ce concours et donc une bonne
carte de visite ça permet d'ouvrir des
portes ça permet de rencontrer du monde
effectivement là les jeunes les jeunes
apprentis qui sont là aujourd'huiah ça
va êtres commis nos employés de demain
quoi donc c'est intéressant de les
rencontrer aussi les concurrents ont
tous beaucoup travaillé en amont mais
malheureusement certains n'arriveront
pas à respecter les délais candidat doit
livrer ses desserts en laissant de côté
quelques ingrédients il a manqué de
temps pour dresser ses assies assiette
temps il y a pas de marqué d' règlement
on peut pas amener de sauce à côté c'est
que à
l'assiettez dans la salle de dégustation
les candidats s'enchaînent ils ont tous
démarré à 7 minutes d'intervalle pour
laisser le temps au juges de goûter
chaque plat un retour en cuisine
allez premier envoie dans une minute car
oui jusqu'au bout Caroline vérifie les
derniers détails tout doit être parfait
pour présenter ses desserts au jury de
dégustation moi aussi je ve
bien bonjour messieurs donc aujourd'hui
moi je vous propose un délice de poire
donc pour la dégustation je vous
conseille de commencer de la plus petite
à la plus grosse comme ça le goût du
chocolat va pas emporter sur le B la
poire voilà excellente dégustation
merci pendant que les chefs dégustent la
jeune pâtissière peut enfin souffler et
et ouais c'est un peu le stress parce
que B même si je me suis bien entraînée
au lycée ici c'est un labo qu'on connaît
pas c'est une pression qui est
complètement différente et en labo je le
faisais en 2 he et1art ben ici pour
vraiment que ça soit parfait pour finer
à fond et tout bah j'ai mis 3 He moins
moins une quoi donc c'est c'est vraiment
c'est clairement différent et mais bon
c'est un bon stress donc bon on verra
quoi de leur côté qu'en on pensé les
juges il y avait une certaine grâce dans
sa présentation c'est très fin sa façon
de travailler ça s'est vu que elle s'est
ba petite bille de
poire son petit décor en chocolat très
fin ça se voit que c'est une fille aussi
qui l'a dressé donc c'était très très
fin mais après le plus important c'était
le goût donc là d'autres candidats ont
été aussi très très performants et après
vous partez directement pas plus il faut
maintenant son mal en patience le
verdict ne sera pas connu avant ce
soir verdict de cette compétition
attendue dans la soirée nous vous
donnerons bien sûr les résultats dans
notre prochaine édition si vous nous
suivez en direct il est presque l'heure
de passer à table forcément notre
question du jour est à savourer
aujourd'hui votre dessert préféré celui
qui vous fait forcément craquer vos
réponses au micro de Patrick Jacques de
dixmud Baba
parce que je ne sais pas le faire c'est
un gâteau léger et que voilà c'est mon
gâteau préféré tarte au
fraise petit
sablé chantilly fraise
classique tarte au citron meringué j'en
ai tellement que voilà on va dire la
crêpe au chocolat avec plein de
Chantilly la tarte aux fraises voilà
tyramisou chocolat gâteau au chocolat
n'importe quel fruit poire
pommes des bananes n'importe des raisins
surtout les fruits la profitrol pourquoi
parce qu'en fait c'est et chaud et froid
et j'adore le chocolat noir la tarte au
citron
meringué la religieux au chocolat et
pourquoi euh c'est bien fourni bien
gourmand et on se régale ah en tant que
pâtissier la Forêt Noire voilà donc pour
ces cerises à Marina la chantilly le
chocolat donc le dessert par excellence
pour moi en tant que prof profnel voilà
tarte au chocolat ou encore tarte au
fraises pourquoi choisir après tout bon
appétit nous en parlions hier soir le
bassin de latonne au château de
Versailles est en réfection depuis
quelques mois une nouvelle étape a été
franchie avec la dépose de l'araignée
c'est le cœur du système hydraulique une
pièce majeur de 4 tonnes qui va être
rénové sur place et les visiteurs
pourront y assister ils vont découvrir
les techniques anciennes de restauration
savoirfaire unique développé par les
fontainiers du château Catherine zulato
et Jonathan
villman
voici le bassin de laatonne dans sa
magnificence 70 jet d'eau qui
jaillissent à profusion de la gueule
d'animaux ou de la bouche des anges et
voici aujourd'hui le même bassin en
cours de restauration car il avait
tendance à s'affaisser toute la
statuaire a déjà été retirée nouvelle
phase avec le déplacement de l'araignée
cette pièce majeure distribue l'ensemble
de l'eau au jet de la Fontaine faite de
plomb et d'éteint elle a été réalisée
sous Louis XIV en 1686
c'est une ellipse donc plusieurs niveaux
de de de de sculpture enfin de statue
qui elle-même crache de l'eau donc il
faut alimenter chacune de ces de ces de
ces statues de ces sculptures donc cette
forme elliptique suit suit la forme du
buffet d'eau alors c'est curieux on a
l'impression de retrouver une une
dissection des artères des veines c'est
dira pres un cœur on dirait presque
presque ça c'est le cœur c'est
objectivement le cœur le cœur
fonctionnel du bassin de la tonne c'est
lui qui permet c'est ce cœur qui permet
de de faire sortir ces fluides cette eau
ce bassin est remarquable parce que bien
sûr il remonte à l'époque de Louis XIV
avec un premier aménagement par le nôtre
et ensuite une transformation par
Mansard on est également au cœur du parc
de Versailles donc c'est le bassin le le
plus
central en quelques minutes la pièce est
soulevée de son écrin de terre pour être
déposée délicatement sur des pièces de
bois c'est là que pendant 2 mois à la
vue de tous les fontainiers du château
vont R cette couronne de 4 tonnes depuis
sa construction elle a jamais été mise à
l'air libre puisquelle était dans la
fontaine cachée et elle é jamais été
extraite donc là c'est vraiment une
chance de pouvoir la voir de près et
puis on va s'atteler à toute cette ces
travaux de restauration de reprise des
fissures l'occasion pour les visiteurs
de rencontrer les fontainiers d'en
savoir plus sur des techniques
ancestrales uniquement connu deux les
soudures sur le plomb sont assez
atypiques et il y a que ici globalement
qu'on essaie de d'entretenir péréniser
ce type d'ouvrage les couronnes de de
fontainerie qui sont les plombs du 17e
avec les soudures à l'ancienne avec les
marques la fleur de LCE tout ce chantier
est conçu aussi pour sauvegarder ce
patrimoine qui est un patrimoine que
personne ne ve ne voit parce qu'il est
caché à l'intérieur mais qui est quand
même un patrimoine technique de très
très grande qualité et qui témoigne d'un
savoir-faire le bassin de la tonne
devrait retrouver tout son éclat au mois
de septembre prochain
pour une mise en eau avant le début de
l'automne un enfant sur trois qui ne
part pas en vacances le Secours
populaire vous propose d'aider ses
enfants partageant une partie de vos
vacances avec lui l'association
recherche actuellement des familles
d'accueil pour les jeunes de 6 11 ans
durant les mois de juillet et les mois
d'août vous pouvez contacter le Secours
populaire des ivelin aux coordonnés qui
sont en train de s'afficher l'invité du
journal c'est thric gastino bonsoir
directeur de l'entreprise envie attrape
une entreprise pas comme les autres chez
vous des salariés en insertion une
vingtaine d'emplois 12 en CDD
d'insertion des CDDI brièvement ça
consiste en quoi ce type de contrat
alors tout d'abord on a à 16 contrats
d'insertion on un peu plus que ce que
vous disz c'est encore progressé j'ai
même pas eu mon chiffre al l'année
dernière on était une dizaine maintenant
16 contrats
d'insertion le contrat d'insertion c'est
un CDD
d'abord on embauche des personnes sur
une durée de 4 mois et on peut
renouveler jusqu'à une durée maximale de
2 ans donc le principe le contenu du du
CDDI c'est de former et d'accompagner
des personnes qui sont en grande
difficulté professionnell et souvent
social euh pour leur permettre à la
sortie d'envit trp de trouver un travail
en CDI euh ou en CDD longue durée h donc
vous remettez un pied à l'étrier à
l'ensemble de ces personnes qui qui
viennent vous voir c'est un magasin euh
comme un autre hein puisque pour le
grand public vous proposz de
l'électroménager rénové et garanti en
vie c'est un magasin donc attrape rue
nkin euh on trouve gadinè frigot qui
sont remis en état exactement on trouve
tout le gros électroménager classique et
le petit électroménager euh la
différence c'est que nous les matériels
on on les récupère d'occasion ils sont
souvent en panne et on les répare on les
rénove on les remet à neuf ça c'est le
travail des personnes en en insertion
donc là eff vous apportez un bagage
technique aussi pour réparer ces
machines aux personnes qui viennent
complètement complètement les personnes
en insertion qui travaillent sur ces
machinesl sont sous la supervision de
deux responsabl technique c'est des
responsables qui ont eu des parcours de
longue durée chez des distributeurs
reconnus donc il y a savoirfire
technique qu'on leur apprend et on les
accompagne tout au long de leur parcours
chez nous pour qu'ils
deviennent des des bonnes agent de
maintenance sans électroménager nos
produits sont vendus sous garantie donc
il est indispensable que ce soit des
produits de qualité vous avez ouvert il
y a un peu plus d'un an est-ce que ça
fonctionne bien aussi bien sur la partie
emploi que sur la partie bah vente tout
simplement parce que c'est aussi le nerf
de la guerre il faut faire rentrer de
l'argent pour que la structure s'alim et
puiss tourner oui vous vous avez raison
de de souligner les deux aspects euh sur
le bilan social que l'on peut faire
après un peu plus d'un an désormais il
est satisfaisant même si on peut
toujours mieux faire euh on a démarré
avec une dizaine de contrats en
insertion euh l'année 2013 s'est déroulé
avec 16 contrats en équivalent temps
plein ça ça veut dire 30 personnes en
fait qui sont passées par la structure
euh on a eu huit personnes qui ont
retrouvé un CDI à à l'issue de un
parcours chez nous c'est un c'est un bon
début je dirais à ce niveau-là et puis
l'équipe vit bien les gens en insertion
chez nous euh sembleent évoluer euh
vraiment dans dans dans le bon sens et
on espère qu'on qu'on aura des encore
des meilleurs résultats l'année
prochaine et sur l'aspect consommateur
client et sur aspect économique là aussi
euh les les premiers résultats sont
prometteurs euh on a fortement développé
notre chiffre d'affaires on est une
entreprise jeune donc on on est
confronté aux problématiques de
croissance de n'importe quelle
entreprise euh on a pour objectif de
doubler notre chiffre d'affaires dans
les 3 années qui viennent h vous avez
reçu hier la visite d'une partie de vos
financeurs parce que c'est un service
d'aide c'est un service public donc la
région notamment intervient et et vous
soutient nous étions présents pour cette
visite guidée et on fait un petit
récapitulatif donc avec ce reportage sur
ce qu'il faut savoir de envie et ensuite
on continue la discussion en
plateau l'association envie à trppe
propose depuis fin 2012 des appareils
électroménagés rénovés et garantis les
clients nont habituellement accès qu'à
ce magasin mais lundi une partie des
financeurs de l'association était invité
à visiter l'arrière boutique envie
récupère ses machines usagées et les
répare et pour cela elle emploie
aujourd'hui une vingtaine de personnes
dont deux emplois d'avenir et 16 CDDI
CDDI ce sont des contrats à durée
déterminée d'insertion on embauche une
personne pour une durée de 4 mois ces
contratsl sont renouvelables jusqu'à une
période maximum de 2 ans le principe
pour nous est pas
d'embaucher de manière durable et
définitive les personnes que l'on
emploie en l'insertion mais c'est de les
accompagner professionnellement et
socialement et de leur donner des outils
pour trouver un emploi durable à la
sortie de l'entreprise le turnover est
donc important mais 50 % des salariés
arrivrive à se réinsérer via un autre
emploi ou une formation
professionnalisante à l'initiative de
cette visite île-de- France Active un
réseau d'association de financement
solidaire qui a prêté à envie 60000 €
mais les investisseurs surtout publics
restent nombreux la région a délivré de
son côté une subvention de 120000 € son
budget annuel pour ce secteur est de 12
millions alors les entreprises
d'économie sociale et solidaire ne
peuvent-elles survivre sans aide elles
reçoivent moins d'Aid que ce que
reçoivent les entreprises françaises de
l'économie dit classique si vous
prenez PSA l'entreprise Peugeot ils ont
reçu plus d'êes que n'importe qui dans
ce pays et pourtant ça le n'empêche pas
de s'écrouler donc les entreprises
d'insertion les entreprises d'économie
sociale et solidaire sont pas les meieux
lotis et arrivent à presque mieux s'en
sortir donc c'est un un faux débat tout
le monde est subventionné dans ce pays
l'association envie arrive à
s'autofinancer à 60 % elle espère
atteindre les 100 % d'ici 3 ans nous
évoquons ce soir dans le 78 lactu le
travail de l'entreprise envie attrape
d'ici 3 ans 100 % d'autofinancement
c'est possible c'est un un objectif
c'est euh c'est ce qu'on espère on a des
exemples dans le réseau enve qui qui est
un réseau national important avec une
cinquantaine d'entreprises exist depuis
les années 80 ça existe depuis 30 ans
effectivement donc on a on a le retour
d'expérience d'entreprise qui fonctionne
bien qui fonctionne même très bien
certaines d'entre elles ne sont plus
vues aujourd'hui comme une association
ni même je dirais comme une entreprise
d'insertion mais comme une entreprise à
part à part entière et ils sont jugés
sur le résultat donc c'est de ces
modèles là que que l'on s'inspire
on est les seuls à exercer notre
activité d'électroménager rénové
garantie en
île-defance on on espère effectivement
suivre le chemin de certaines autres
entités et d'avoir les mêmes succès le
succès était le même justement vous me
disiez avant cet entretien que vous avez
même réussi à vous développer plus
rapidement que les autres structures du
du réseau en vie peut-être il y en a une
cinquantaine d'antennes en vie travers
la France oui le le le le projet en
vitraap s'est développé
rapidement grâce aussi au soutien qui a
été évoqué dans le reportage de de nos
partenaires ça a permis à l'entreprise
d'acquérir une
dimension qui laassenne aujourd'hui
assez vite un an on va dire de
d'activité commerciale c'est c'est c'est
peu et le résultat aujourd'hui et c'est
630000 € de chiffre d'affaires sur la
vente des produits et et la collecte
financé par l'écoorganisme écosystème
c'est 23 personnes au total 23 salariés
au total de
l'entreprise c'est un début mais c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt un un bébé qui est
bien né et qu'on espère encore une fois
développé rapidement c'est c'est tout
l'enjeu de de l'année qui vient euh
c'est pas acquis c'est pas facile mais
euh on on on on essaie de parler le plus
possible de l'entreprise de la qualité
de nos produits et de la qualité de
notre mission d'accompagnement et de
formation de de nos salariés euh pour
que le le projet se développe le plus
vite possible je Seris juste faire une
parenthèse pour revenir sur les types de
contrats que vous vous proposez on
parlait des CDDI donc ces contrats
d'insertion à durée déterminée il y a
aussi des emplois d'avenir que vous
proposer et aujourd'hui vous avez
accueilli pour la première fois une
nouvelle salariée une nouvelle salariée
dans ce c'est une femme pour une fois
oui alors pour une fois c'est pas tout à
fait exact dans la structure on a on a
des enfin on a des CDI euh permanent
mais on a on avait déjà deux emplois
d'avenir femme euh là c'est la première
fois qu'on a à la vente en fait une
femme et et ça nous fait très plaisir en
fait c'est assez euh difficile pour
nousin c'est vraiment pas une volonté
c'est difficile pour nous de recruter du
personnel féminin euh sur les postes
d'opérateurs de réparateurs euh et de
maintenance de machines euh on en a eu
euh mais c'est c'est c'est pas c'est
très très largement minoritaire dans la
population qu'on accueille donc là on
est très heureux d'accueillir euh euh
une nouvelle nouvelle salarié en CDI
emploi d'avenir et qui sera à la vente
au magasin le message à faire passer
c'est quoi pour conclure c'est qu'un
autre modèle économique est possible
modèlec conomique entre recyclage
environnement aussi et puis vraiment
volonté de formation d'insertion sociale
oui complètement ce qui a été dit dans
le reportage est très juste en fait il
faut sortir de de la caricature de
l'association aidé subventionné on on
doit réussir des résultats économiques
avec un certain nombre de facteurs qui
qui ne sont pas économiques qui sont
plutôt même antiéconomiques c'est tout
l'intérêt et tout l'enjeu de notre
mission donc on peut faire à la fois du
développement durable de l'écologie du
social et et avoir une crédibilit
économique et faire tourner une
entreprise merci er gastinau d'être venu
directeur de l'entreprise envie attrape
vous trouverez d'électroménager à
moindre coût une bonne action pour une
entreprise qui développe vous l'avez
entendu un vrai projet social merci
encore à vous nous allons voir à présent
tout autre sujet que la philosophie ça
n'est pas que pour les adultes les
enfants aussi font travailler leur
méning exemple à l'estaminé et c'est à
manilamo une fois par mois anneesophie
aborde des questions de société avec les
7 à 10 ans tout cela sans leurs parents
reportage Jolen Torz et Jonathan villman
c'est jeunes philosophes ont entre 7 et
10 ans un samedi par mois à l' staminé
de Manil eto ils débattent réfléchissent
et s'interroge sur des grands thèmees de
société ce mois-ci la grande question
était pourquoi on meurt chacun avait sa
petite idée parce que si on est trop
dans le monde on pourrait plus vivre il
aurait plus d'air bah parce que le
cerveau il marche plus ou le cœur il
marche
plus et parce qu'on est vieux ou par une
maladie c'est comme si tu étais en train
de jouer et que voilà tu meurs jamais
quoi c'est c'est j'appelle ça de la
Truche faut bien qu'on meure un moment
c'est la deuxè année qu'Anne Sophie
anime cet atelier l'objectif est de
permettre aux enfants de s'exprimer sans
tabou de développer leur esprit critique
et d'apprendre à s'écouter malgré leur
innocence leurs propos ne sont pas
dénués de sens leur pertinence elle est
elle est vraiment toujours là
quoi je trouve que par rapport à des
adultes les idées sont les mêmes elles
sont juste exprimées différemment mais
je c'est surû tout le monde envie d'être
heureux mais on peut pas l'être on peut
pas l' tous chaque fois il y a un peu de
poésie par exemple le petit garçon qui a
parlé de du jeu de loi pour résumer un
peu ce quiétait la vie on avance d'une
case chaque jour je trouvais ça assez
joli et puis après le petit garçon un
des petits garçons qui n'a pas trop
participé mais qui sur la fin quand je
lui ai demandé ce qu'il allait dessiner
sur le tableau pour résumer un peu le
débat il a voulu faire une horloge et je
trouvais que c'était aussi une idée
assez pertinente par rapport à la mort
pendant 1 heure c'est aussi l'occasion
pour ces jeunes de parler sans la
présence des parents c'est intéressant
de discuter entre enfants aussi parce
que c'est
différent de des discussions avec les
adultes et puis aussi c'est pas avec les
parents donc c'est aussi voilà un espace
libre pour eux donc je trouve ça bien
qu'ils puissent commencer à réfléchir
par eux-mêmes sur leur propré c'est des
concepts qui sont importants à adhérer
au plus tôt dans la vie pour avoir un
petit peu déjà des axes de pour se
construire quoi tout simplement voilà
après ben aussi avoir un avis autre que
les parents parce qu'on a pas la science
infuse en toutess d'oublier parce que
sinon après c'est triste de penser
toujours à à la personne qui est Mor
prochain thème abordé le 8 mars prochain
les filles et les
garçons culture jusqu'au 2 février
l'espace de Coville à voisin le
Bretonneux le club des collectionneurs
des evelines expose ses plus belles
pièces une occasion de découvrir des
objets d'hier et d'aujourd'hui de
rencontrer tout simplement des
passionnés aurellia debissi et Étienne
Dang ils sont molabophil numismat ou
encore les ctiophiles autrement dit ils
sont collectionneurs d'anciens moulins à
café de pièces de monnaie ou de flacons
de parfum ces passionnés d'objets d'hier
ou d'aujourd'hui exposent leur trésors
jusqu'au 2 février à l'espace de Coville
de voisin le Bretonneux une exposition
multicollection organisé par le Club des
collectionneurs des ivelines le club
réunit un certain nombre de passionnés
une cinquantaine qui se réunissent une
fois tous les de mois et partagent leur
trouvaill de toute l'année et ESS de les
mettre à la disposition du public au
travers par exemple de l'exposition
d'aujourd'hui je suis donc un pomelcofil
autrement dit quelqu'un qui collectionne
des tir bouchons une une petite pièce
effectivement du 18e moitié du 18e qui
est donc un tirebouchon à parfum qui est
en argent et qui a et qui a quand même
une certaine valeur on peut nous pouvons
dire donc aujourd'hui des tirbouchons
anglais dont j'ai j'ai quelque chose une
une préférence parce que nous aurons par
exemple des manches en corne d'autres en
ivoire d'autres dans des bois précieux
je considère que pour l'instant ce sont
les les mîtres en la matière
si vous dénichez des trésors dans vos
greniers vous pouvez faire appel aux
collectionneurs du club des Yvelines qui
peuvent vous aider à les évaluer demain
mercredi dès 18h le journal revient le
78 lactu vous sera présenté par
Catherine zulato à suivre ce soir sur
TVfil 78 municipale 2014 avec un focus
sur saint-ir l'école et sur morp avec
deux candidats qui se présentent sur ces
communes toute l'actualité du scrutin
qui est aussi à retrouver sur notre site
Internet grâce au replay de différentes
émissions et différents reportages
excellente soirée